[Music]  Alexis Ohanian cheered on wife serena  williams at wimbledon and it was  hilarious i think that's definitely true  according to these pics of her husband  we'd say so the 35 year old tech  entrepreneur was not shy about  supporting the tennis pro while in the  stands during day 5 of the historic  tennis tournament in london alexis was  seen throwing his fists in the air  flexing his muscles and shouting in  celebration as his wife took the court  squaring off against france's kristina  mladenovic  i don't know if there's anything left  for me but i'm not done yet  she's definitely not done yet serena  defeated her opponent in the second set  alexis was so proud of his ladylove he  took to Instagram to show even more  supports sharing a funny photo from the  event writing in the caption mama got me  hyped for the weekend even if I will be  on my laptop I'm typing with gusto  [Music]  you